les vêlages bardaine êtes venus
jusqu'ici nous voir c'est parce que vous
nous
mais comment ont-ils été jaloux sais
c'est pas du tout notre shore de chalus
six ans devraient vraiment vous
remercier d'avoir permis s'est tournée
suite à votre déplorable incompétence on
devrait leur faire livrer ou grand bay
de fruits nous y sommes bien vous vous
préférez des minimes fine on n'est pas
venu pour lancer les hostilités juste
pour se faire une idée sur vous avant
les mondiaux où vous éclatera torah
c'est toi qui éclatent les champs ah oui
tu es si frêle on dirait un elfe ou
alors une fait un lutin tyson teichmann
trouille
c'est ça on dirait un troll toi tu as
une plastique parfaite
merci tu me plais pas pour autant dakar
on n'a pas peur des mondiaux quand les
belhassine sur scène compter sur elle
pour vous scotcher avec quoi encore le
barbu dhabi la barrique et c'est pas ça
mon nom je ne les connais pas ça peut
être n'importe quoi malraux ta nou grâce
la feignasse ou claire l'autorité madame
east émis la baleine ou ne fait qu'une
bouchée des teutons dans ton genre votre
équipe est comment dire une totalement
nulle nullité absolue le niveau zéro
mais au carré tu vois parce que 0 s'est
pas encore assez nul pour vous